the attention span is getting shorter
and shorter and so Tick Tock gives you
sort of instant gratification I think
with Tick Tock at some point like 8 out
of 10 videos that they show you you're
interested in which is probably a little
scary to think about the tick tock
Creator fund pays essentially nothing
like the most amount of money that I've
ever made from The Tick Tock Creator
fund I think I had gotten around 50 or
60 million views in that month I want to
say I made around like 1500 bucks
wow you also run blackrock's Tick Tock
account it was Larry Fink's idea Larry
Fink wanted to get on Tick Tock yes it
is wild somebody watches this like all
right cool I got it tick tock's big I
should be on Tick Tock what would you
say are like the three to five steps
that somebody should do immediately to
grow on Tick Tock all right guys bang
bang I've got Matt here uh I'm in my
mid-30s and one of the most popular
questions I get over and over and over
again is people saying what is Tick Tock
uh when I think of tick tock I think of
the geopolitical concerns I think of a
bunch of people in Tech being like we
should support it we should ban it we
should whatever but one thing you can't
deny is that is this massive platform
that young people are definitely using
uh you have multiple accounts that are
very popular on Tick Tock like why is
Tick Tock working and like help people
understand like what exactly is going on
on Tick Tock for those that aren't there
yeah
um first off thank you for having me of
course uh it's an honor I feel like
you're you're kind of like a North star
for a lot of like business creators so
I'm like I'm honored to be here
um but yeah I think as far as tick tock
goes the
main reason that I I think it works is
that like the attention span is getting
shorter and shorter right
um and so Tick Tock gives you sort of I
guess both as the Creator and as a
consumer it gives you this like instant
gratification where it's like if you
don't want to see something uh if you're
watching the video uh if you're
uninterested you can just keep scrolling
and uh you'll find a video that you like
very quickly because their algorithm is
so good
um so I think like in short the reason
that it works so well is that it's just
it's easy
so we saw 2020 I think maybe was like a
big year uh from an explosion of tick
tock obviously a bunch of people uh uh
got these huge audiences they became
like culturally relevant and they've
kind of spanned from there uh I've seen
a lot of people build their audience
first on Tick Tock and then try to go
elsewhere should we read into that as to
like this is a good place to build an
initial audience but like there's not a
lot of money to be made or like why are
people maybe building the audiences
initially there and then trying to get
on these other platforms well I think uh
I guess like a similar thing happened to
me where
um I'd always had friends who were you
know making money on YouTube uh and Tick
Tock came around and it just seemed like
a really easy thing to get into
um and so I started making Tick Tock
videos and it was super easy and then I
think everyone kind of goes through this
thing where they're like okay well what
am I going to do next right
um and I think like the obvious next
step is YouTube Just because it's like
more complicated you want to like grow
as a Creator and I guess like like an
artist of like making videos um still
video content still similar in terms of
the types of content you could create
with shorts versus Tick Tock or whatever
right
um the problem is that I've seen it
translate well very rarely interesting
yeah why is that
um well I just think like
I just think that long-form YouTube
videos and Tick Tock videos are very
very different
um you know Tick Tock is more like a lot
of attention grabbing as where YouTube I
believe is like a little more you know
uh relatable authentic uh and so at the
same time if you have a lot of Instagram
followers and you built that organically
I guess nowadays like not through reels
um those followers genuinely are like or
generally are like really there for you
and so if you post about your YouTube
channel a lot of them will probably
convert but on Tick Tock it's not that
way
so when you think about Tick Tock one of
the things I've heard maybe read from
night media talk about is like if he had
to choose where he'd want people to have
an audience it'd be YouTube long form
YouTube because they know who you are
they get emotionally attached and all
this stuff do you think that
Tick Tock doesn't have that or like what
is the relationship you have you know
almost 4 million followers on Tick Tock
what is your relationship and the
content you create with the audience if
you tweet it out or post it somewhere
that you were going to be somewhere
would people show up would they not show
up like how does this work yeah I mean
there's definitely a lot less of that
with tick talkers right like there's a
lot less if I had 4 million on YouTube
my experience would be totally different
um and so I think that has a lot to do
with the fact that people are spending
less time with you
um you know if somebody if somebody is
on YouTube and they're posting
two long form videos a week let's say
they're 10 15 minutes those people are
spending 20 to 30 minutes a week with
you and
at the same time like YouTubers the
entire video generally are like not just
spending that entire time trying to keep
the retention rate up they're not being
like overly you know uh energetic uh and
so I think with YouTube it kind of feels
like your friends a little bit more as
we're with Tick Tock it's like just
these little like tidbits of information
people might think it's interesting so
maybe they'll follow you
um but with YouTube it's yeah I think
it's just a totally different ball game
everyone wants to know how do you make
money on Tick Tock you are unique in
that uh you have a personal account
that's pretty big you've created other
accounts that are big uh you run
accounts for other companies uh and
there's like advertising talk a little
bit maybe about your account the start
uh how did you grow it and then how did
you actually end up monetizing yeah
um so I started my ticket my Tick Tock
account just with the goal of like
making videos about things that I cared
about which generally was business or
content uh Creator related like Creator
economy stuff
um and so after a little bit I kind of
realized what worked well which was like
you know making sure you're hooking
people making sure that at the end of
the video they're satisfied with what
they watched
um
Etc and we can get into you know more of
the more of those things after but
explain that so there's like a formula
for a video yeah yeah I think uh I think
it depends on the person right like I
think no matter who you are it needs to
be interesting in the beginning
um
and so with me it's like I'll generally
say something that sounds a little bit
ridiculous in the beginning uh so that
someone will be like what the hell is
this guy talking about right
um and so then they'll continue to watch
the video and hopefully understand what
I was saying in the beginning eventually
um so that's that's kind of the goal
there but I think with different people
like the format can be different
um like there are people who have these
like really great personalities
naturally like on and off camera and I
think that some of those people can
literally just like you know put their
phone up press record and say what
they're thinking about and for some
reason five million people like want to
hear about it you know
um so yeah it's just it's really
interesting there's like a ton of
different ways to do it so you catch
their attention in the beginning you
mentioned that they're satisfied at the
end how do you measure that or or how do
you think about making sure that happens
well I think it's just making sure that
like in the beginning you have to like
kind of ride this line between like
whether or not you're just like saying
something that's like complete BS
uh or like like I think for what I do
for example like I'll say something like
you know
Andrew Tate is lying to everybody right
um which I think a lot of people would
disagree with uh in some in some areas
maybe I would disagree with that uh so
like you say something like General that
makes people want to stay and then at
the end I think people would be like
okay I get what he's saying you know as
where if I were to say something totally
ridiculous and then not be able to back
it up at all I think people would just
be pissed off so it's almost like make a
outlandish statement a big statement
whatever terminology you want to use you
make some statement in the beginning you
grab people's attention and they use the
rest of the video to basically explain
what you what you mean by that and if
you do a good job of catching their
attention and then they stay to get the
explanation they're satisfied at the end
right so like with I made a video for
example when like Mr Beast launched
Beast Burger in the beginning of that
video I could have just been like hey
guys you know Mr Beast launch Beast
Burger here's why it's cool or here's
why it's important uh but the beginning
of that video was like Mr Beast is going
to be the first content creator
billionaire ever and here's why right so
it's like
it's super short they don't know like
exactly what I'm talking about so it
like Sparks a little bit of like
curiosity
um and then by the end of their by the
end of the video they're hopefully like
okay I get it and on Tick Tock uh do
they need to do anything to help it go
viral or is it just if they just stay
and watch like YouTube is they just stay
and watch uh YouTube's like cool
completion times is really important
we're going to send this viral a podcast
has no virality to it in the audio
format and somebody has to literally
share it or word of mouth and that's
really the only way that it gets popular
what is Tick Tock yeah um I think it's
pretty similar to something like YouTube
or you know Instagram where I think
everything is is weighed pretty pretty
well like if a video has a ton of shares
comments likes uh and I think Tick Tock
pays a lot of attention to like exactly
what people are doing
um so I think like if a lot of people
are going to your page and watching your
other videos and following you from like
one specific video then they'll push
that video
and how much of this is just tick tock's
algorithm is better than YouTube's
the reason or is that not even true
I don't know that it's true I think
they're just really
print uh I think Tick Tock can like or I
guess I guess maybe it is like better in
a way because I think Tick Tock can
Target people like even more you know if
you if you go to YouTube you know
assuming you have a YouTube account and
you go to the home page uh there's
probably a video or two that you're
interested in there but I think with
Tick Tock if you've been scrolling on on
The Tick Tock for you page for like a
month
uh at some point like you know eight out
of 10 videos that they show you you're
interested in which is probably a little
scary to think about yeah well and I
guess also
um as they get better and better uh and
they get more data the big question I
have is YouTube's been doing this now
for you know forever how much harder is
it for YouTube just given the amount of
content they have to you know kind of
pick through to show you versus The Tick
Tock which tells a ton of videos most
popular website all you know all the
things we know uh but I'd love to see
what are the total number of videos on
YouTube versus the total number of
videos uploaded to tick tock my guess is
YouTube is still like much much more
from a video standpoint I'd be surprised
if it wasn't and so YouTube has a
problem uh which a good problem to have
but it's still a problem you gotta find
through billions of videos which is the
one to show Matt that so that he watches
it versus you know the next one right
yeah definitely
um and also YouTube videos have a longer
lifespan which I think makes that
problem even more relevant to them
explain that so on Tick Tock if a video
like explodes
usually like nine times out of ten of
course there's outliers I'll I'll notice
that it dies uh you know after five or
seven days even if it's like huge right
like I think my biggest video got like
almost 25 million views and so
that video was only really growing for
like
it's probably closer to seven days but
that was it is we have a video on
YouTube gets 25 million views it's
probably been up for a little while
um so yeah I think I think with Tick
Tock that problem is a little bit easier
for them too because like they're really
feeding you like new-ish things at least
in comparison to YouTube
um so yeah that's a really good point
I've never thought of that so when you
think of your personal account what are
the different ways that you monetize
there is it all Advertising based or do
you have other other things you do yeah
um so with my personal account forever
it's just simply been ads
um which is scary in comparison to
YouTubers because most YouTubers
assuming you know you're not like
uh really inappropriate or using a ton
of copyrighted stuff you're monetized
you're usually making enough money uh if
you're doing it full-time like you're
usually making pretty consistent money
month over month
um so for me in the beginning it was
scary right because one month you could
make tens of thousands of dollars and
for three months you could make
nothing zero close to it right uh
especially because like the tick tock
Creator fund pays
essentially nothing like the most amount
of money that I've ever made from The
Tick Tock Creator fund uh
I think I had gotten around 50 or 60
million views in that month and I I want
to say I made around like 1500 bucks
wow so if you're getting that amount of
views like on YouTube email is flooded
with brand deals to the point where like
that 1500 bucks means nothing um
as where yeah on YouTube it's like
it's it's not even comparable like it's
not even close so 50 to 60 million views
in a month uh your email was flooded
yeah and what are people saying like hey
make me a video can you mention my
product in a video like what are they
looking for yeah it's mostly Brands and
I mean you know ninety percent of the
emails you get are like some random
Amazon Seller like looking to see if
he'll sell their purple wigs right like
something that's totally irrelevant
um and something that's just not going
to work and most of them will offer you
like 200 bucks that's the other thing
too is like the I think the ad rates
there's this huge like Gap right where
some I think Tick Tock is still so new
that like some people don't realize like
what the rates are like so it's really
all over the place
um does that help or hurt you
um
probably mostly hurt because like most
of the time you have to kind of justify
it
um and be like hey listen like you could
go to this person this person and this
person who's like I guess in the same
like bucket as me
but they charge just as much if not more
and so you have to like there's this
extra step of like you kind of have to
prove to a company uh like why erase her
the way they are
um but I think it's all getting better
now like I feel like a lot of brands
have uh you know given pushback a little
bit less and how do you decide so your
inbox is full of all these people who
are like hey advertise my product from
purple wigs to things you actually might
do how do you decide which ones to work
with and which one's not is it a price
thing is it a product thing is it a
combination yeah uh it's definitely a
combination I think a lot of people
would be kind of ashamed to say like the
money is important because like you'd
like to think that it's not uh but it is
right like if the person you're running
out of business of course it's important
if the if the perfect fit of a company
like you know that like the ads gonna
work out well they fit right in with
your page your audience isn't gonna like
be pissed off at you for promoting them
if you should be getting ten thousand
dollars and they're offering you 500
like you're way too far apart right
um so yeah I think it's definitely a
common Nation like
and what do you do in that scenario so
like you you want ten thousand dollars
for a video somebody offers you 500 do
you negotiate do you try to send them
comps do you just say come back when you
got ten thousand dollars like how do you
handle that
um well if nothing's aligned
you know sometimes I guess it depends on
like how flooded the inbox is but
sometimes it's like a no answer kind of
situation yeah of course um
but yeah I mean otherwise like what if
it's the perfect company like if you're
like man this is going to fly on the
page
yeah um well it depends like if it's a
startup there have been times where I've
been like okay well maybe we can make
this up in equity right like if I really
if I'm if I really think and I have a
few friends who are like very familiar
with like the VC space so I'll like ask
them hey what do you think about this
company and they'll check out like you
know how much funding they have and like
who's backing them and like kind of give
me their thoughts
um so
if they're willing to like uh give in
and like make that up with Equity then
there have been a few times where like
I've done that yeah got it okay so it's
all advertising on your page why don't
you sell things you don't know what to
sell is it that's not kind of how Tick
Tock works yeah
um
well yeah I think I think it's kind of a
combination of both like on Tick Tock
you really need to be like
a certain type of Creator to be able to
sell stuff
um just because your audience isn't
quite as engaged as if you were on
YouTube
um
and so yeah I think for me it's like
it's much easier to just stick with the
brand deals and obviously recently like
I've started with selling like
B2B right like we were talking about
before we started the podcast like uh
I've been running Brands Tick Tock
accounts for them
um so I think that like through through
that and like uh advertising those are
probably at least from my account
uh the like most plausible ways to to
make money so you go to a brand we'll
talk about which brands in a second but
you go to a brand you say hey I'll run
your account for you what are they
expecting you to do is it like you
literally get them the handle and like
set up the page and then you tell them
what to post are you creating all the
content how does this work yeah um so I
think it's obviously super important for
Brands to be on Tick Tock right like or
at least be making short form video
um like we were talking before about how
like Tick Tock might be banned people
are scared but I don't think short form
videos going away
um and so I think that that's like
something that a lot of Brands and
especially I think startups should be
focusing on now and a lot of them meant
over the last like two years have
started
um but I think like my whole pitch is
kind of like
you know if you're gonna grab some kid
who you know was in studied marketing
and is fresh out of college and you're
gonna pay him 100 Grand why wouldn't you
just come to me right like I've been I
have like real experience with this uh
and so I think a lot of Brands now
hopefully uh will start coming to me and
if not me people like me
um
to to do that
I've always thought uh you could go get
a marketing degree or if you show up
with like a hundred thousand uh
followers or you know in this case
millions of followers on an account uh
if you want to go get a job at one of
these companies and it was like you
versus like the degree like you're gonna
win it all day long because you're like
cool that person like read some books
and I listened to a professor but like I
know how to do this like here's proof
yeah right and so it is that real world
experience uh this is true of everything
like in sales right if you show up to
the job interviews I was like oh I have
a sales degree and somebody else is like
nah man like I got three leads where who
do I send these to internally right
people like I guess that guy could do
the job yeah definitely and so as far as
expectations goes
um it's really all over the place right
because like a lot of brands are just in
totally different spots you know
um I guess this is a good time to bring
this up like blackrock's Tick Tock
account for example uh which you guys
run right uh so they already had a tick
tock account set up and they already
knew that they want wanted their
employees to be in the videos okay
so their expectation was just like hey
we have this set up
um but you know we could probably use a
little more force behind this
how do you do this right and so and do
they have like a uh so for context uh
you got your account you've got other
brand accounts you also run blackrock's
Twitter account or a tick tock account
and for those that are like wait
BlackRock like the the BlackRock yes
BlackRock like the trillions of dollars
of assets uh has a tick tock that you're
running uh in in partnership with them
who's coming up with you let's just go
through step by step like okay you work
with a brand like BlackRock who comes up
with the ideas are you like hey guys
here's 10 ideas that you could do are
they coming to you and they're like
here's 10 things that we want to do like
make it go viral so this is interesting
I guess we'll like go back to the
beginning of my partnership with them so
I ended up connecting with someone from
their uh in their social media
Department
um and the whole Tick Tock thing was
actually it was Larry Fink's idea he was
like we got to get on Tick Tock Larry
Fink wanted to get on Tick Tock yes it's
wild and so they were like we got to get
going like we're we're trying to push on
this right because like of course you
know when when Larry wants something
like
so uh it was like a very it was like a
very quick thing right so just kind of
like threw me in because they were like
we want to we were looking for someone
who like kind of knows what they're
doing
um and so and they just like email you
is it like cold email
yeah so like I was connected with uh
this girl from there on on LinkedIn and
I remember like she posted something one
day like we're looking for a tick tock
Creator and I was like this is perfect
so I just like shot her a message and I
was like hey I'm curious to hear more
about this
so we started like pretty like
immediately
um and so
what I started doing with them and what
I'm trying to do uh through fuse my
agency uh with like startups is
is just like everything right like a
like a door-to-door kind of service like
all you have to do is approve the videos
we'll do everything else
um and so with them it's it's pretty
much that and obviously like their
compliance is a little bit heavier than
than a bunch of like startups that I've
worked with
um so there's like a little bit more to
the approval process but yeah I mean
it's essentially just like me and then
there's a few other people from their
team who kind of like
suggest things that they should talk
about like to ensure that they're like
staying on brand you know
um so it's kind of like they'll they'll
talk like they'll they'll come with some
ideas and say Hey you know
we'd like to talk about this and then
I'll try to kind of uh
figure out how to talk about that in a
way that could be like digestible on
Tick Tock and then do you give them like
a script and they have their employees
like uh read the script or like how does
that work in terms of you getting the
content you need to be able to edit so
the video is yeah this episode is
brought to you by eight sleep good sleep
is a game changer and the eight sleep
pod is the best sleep machine I sleep on
it every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founder so let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep so once the
video Once the like the video ideas are
laid out
um we'll like write a bunch of scripts
uh take them to like their legal and
compliance they'll uh you know approve
them we'll make changes whatever it may
be
um and then we'll like set like a
filming day in their office and so it
actually works out well because I live
in New York and they're
headquarters in New York so uh like
probably one day every like you know two
weeks three weeks or whatever I'll roll
into black rock yeah do you bring like
the influencer uh light and like a
camera and everything which is crazy
yeah
yeah I'll go into their office and it's
it's nuts like uh
I
stick out actually well
I don't want to sound like you know like
I'm like [ __ ] on them at all because
like their their marketing department is
actually really like it's mostly young
people of course
um but still it like it is Blackrock
right so like it's like pretty like I go
in like this like hat and everything and
like nobody does that in an LA Dodgers
hat in New York no no no you're usually
not actually it's a sore topic right now
we don't got to talk about the Yankees
um so
yeah it's uh
it's not good sorry are you from New
York huh are you from New York uh my old
family is here
so when you walk into BlackRock uh
are they like excited yeah like the
employees are gonna be in the videos
they're like yeah they're really cool
like we're we're like we're all friends
it's nice yeah so they're like cool I
get to be in a Black Rock Tick Tock
video yeah but like they're building so
like the like I said the marketing
Department's really cool uh but like if
you walk into the lobby you'll notice
like most people are wearing like suits
they look real serious and so like I
remember the first day walking in the
real jobs
so like I remember the first day walking
in there's like a ton of security on on
the in the lobby and whatever and uh the
guy was like Hey like you looking for
something like what's that like why are
you here yeah like kind of just like
what are you doing like you don't look
like you belong here yeah um and I
remember being like Yep this is perfect
this is exactly what I wanted with my
life
um so yeah yeah so I'll go into their
office we'll film the videos and then uh
you know edit them afterwards get more
approvals and then they get posted and
stuff and what is the purpose is it they
want to be culturally relevant with a
certain demographic do they want is it
like a recruiting thing is there are
they trying to make money are they
trying to sell ads on their BlackRock
Tick Tock account like what was the
purpose
um well I think
I think there's two things I don't wanna
I don't get any trouble so I'm not
speaking on behalf of them this is your
speculation
um but yeah I think if I had to guess uh
I think that they're
trying to like tap into the youth
um which like you know anyone who's
listening to this probably knows that
the best way to tap into the youth
nowadays is tick tock
um and so I think that's part of it and
then also like their whole thing is
really like an initiative to uh teach
people more about like Financial
Wellness
um and so I think it's definitely like a
long-term game for them because it's not
like you know in any of the videos it's
not advertising like Aladdin or any of
their like products generally I mean
sometimes like if if it fits like we
could mention it like it doesn't hurt to
just make mention of it but um
yeah I think so generally it's just like
promoting Financial wellness and I think
perhaps planting the seed for the Youth
yeah which makes sense right like if if
you were sitting there at that
organization you're like man I'm gonna
think really long term uh we probably
want our brand in front of young people
who may come work here one day maybe
customers one day uh maybe buyers at
other companies that were trying to pit
like it makes sense to get your brand in
front of them and for the cost or like
if you think of like from a risk return
standpoint it's like minimal cost
compared to the potential uh benefit
that they could get yeah yeah I mean at
this point
you know it's been less than six months
and they're they're following his
I don't know probably close to 10x by
now how many uh followers they have well
it's they have like I think
seventeen thousand eighteen thousand
Seventeen they got more than me really
yeah I think we got 15. yeah and so but
they started with you know I think 1500
something like that
um all right enough about BlackRock
they're not paying me any money so like
this is not a BlackRock ad uh go follow
my tick tock
uh when when you think about the
business that you're running though so
you run those types of accounts there's
also startup type accounts as well is it
all brand recognition brand awareness uh
or do you see some of these companies
trying to do like direct response stuff
on Tupac as well yeah I mean I think
it's a little bit of both right I think
it's I think it kind of depends on like
where the company's at
um some of the startups that are like
super
um you know
small just getting started they're
looking for conversions
um and so but then there are some that
are kind of just looking to like looking
for that awareness right like I don't
know if you're familiar with carrot
uh they do like credit cards or they're
technically not credit cards for
influencers so
um we are hopefully by the time this is
out uh we'll start running their account
um and they for they for example like
we're kind of just like we want to make
cool videos that like attract
influencers specifically because like
their Niche is like very specific right
like you can't get a carrot card if you
know you're not an influencer
um
and then there are other companies like
there's one uh also not sure if you're
familiar it's called here
um they do like this is not an ad but uh
they they do like it's like fractional
you can buy into like fractional shares
of like Airbnb Airbnb rentals okay
um they're actually based here in Miami
too uh so like we're running theirs and
theirs is more targeted to like we want
conversions right yep like
um so yeah so when you do like uh
content for them are you in the videos
or are you getting other people are you
getting their employees yeah
um
so I think like I'm open to being in the
videos but the
I'm really focused on like scalability
here because one of the things that I
noticed about like my ads on Tick Tock
for example is like you can only have so
many ads so like for example the rest of
this year I can't take any more ads
um why because you're sold out yeah
pretty much because like you you can't
uh you know if half your videos are ads
like you're just gonna destroy your
audience
um and so I've noticed that with this
it's it's pretty scalable like uh I can
I like to spend a lot of time with like
the people who I work with who are like
touching this so that they can like
figure out how I think about things and
can like sort of start to do things the
way that I would like Reese for example
has been like a huge help with all of
this and uh he's been working with me
for over a year now maybe even close to
two
um how's YouTube Meet uh so Reese
actually sent me uh like a cold email
um and I was like
yeah this seems interesting sure because
his little thing was like uh
I I'm just really interested in this
like I'll do it for free so he didn't
even get paid for like six months or
whatever right and then whatever he was
he was great and he graduated college
and now it's like a full-time thing
um
and so yeah like I think the goal is to
like
kind of like have a balance between like
retaining as much quality as I can and
also like having the capability to scale
uh because it's like how do we put out
more videos how do we put out better
videos
um and how do we also make sure that
Brands feel like they're getting the
proper attention from me because that is
usually like a pretty big part of the
the pitch
um
and so yeah I mean I think I think it's
pretty much just about like finding good
people which I'm sure you know is like
the toughest and one of the most
important things
um and then also like
kind of being uh you know strict with
like which brands we choose to work with
um because like I think it's really
tough like when when a company will like
is willing to give you a bunch of money
right but you don't want anything to
look bad like you don't want your brain
to look bad if if the company is no
offense boring and you there's just no
content opportunities there like I'm
just it doesn't make sense even to get
paid uh even if you're getting paid to
like take that time to make uh you know
videos for an account that might not
really do anything there there is uh I
bet you that we could make 10 times more
money across all the different uh
advertising deals that we've done over
the years we could have made easily 10
times more money if we accepted all of
the boring people uh the people that we
thought uh were like not something I
really want to be associated with either
because of the people because of the
product because of the market whatever
uh if you have a growing audience or a
big audience I think that people
underestimate how much opportunity there
is but the people who stay in this game
for a long time you have to make sure
that you pick correctly right and it
feels like Tick Tock is like that on
steroids like it's the Wild Wild West
yeah and and I think like
you get tested a lot right like recently
what's the test that you went through uh
it was very recent okay uh don't use me
we'll say the Brand's name
um but it was uh I'll give you five
dollars if you said
five bucks I'll take it
um see he'll do anything for money yeah
it was uh it was a like a sports betting
and other types of betting thing okay
um and they were really really pushy
about like
basically like you need to encourage
people in a legal way to uh start
gambling and we want you to get on
Twitch and start streaming your self
gambling we'll give you money for that
and whatever
and they offered like it was like a full
year deal and it was like close to a
million dollars a million dollars for a
full year for you to post on Tick Tock
and stream on Twitch which by the way is
definitely is much that's a much bigger
I don't want to give like the wrong uh
impression it's a much bigger offer than
like I have ever gotten
um for like one single thing uh so that
was like testing right because it's like
almost a million bucks like I don't have
to sweat for the next year
um but at the end of the day it's just
like I think
I think it would just weigh down on my
conscience too much because it's pulling
people towards gambling
yeah I mean especially with like the way
that they wanted their messaging to be
was not like you know I think I think
some people could maybe see it
differently if it's if it's the type of
thing where
um you know you kind of just show
yourself gambling and maybe like an
interesting clip or whatever but this
was specifically like hey you know
they'll they'll go ahead and uh you know
double your first deposit and you know
like a lot of just incentives for people
to start gambling and I think especially
on Tick Tock with like younger audiences
like you don't want to plant that seed
yeah I think the younger audience but
also uh one of the things I've thought a
lot about we've worked with some of the
gambling companies before but it's
always been from a perspective of like
this is entertainment you should use
minimal dollars right we've been
approached by people uh and thankfully
we're not like sports or whatever where
this is like crazy uh who are like put
all of your money in and like you'll get
yeah right and I think that there is uh
it's very similar in crypto as well
right like if you think whether uh there
is like buying Bitcoin
um on an exchange whether it is in your
retirement account like there's all
these different products now and I
always remind the brands like
you shouldn't tell people uh that they
should or should not do something you
shouldn't pass judgment on them right
obviously uh you want people to use your
stuff but like the message that will
resonate is actually one that is
rational not one that's like super over
the top uh and so and I see some people
who are like super over the top and
you're just like I got it like they were
shopping a deal and it kind of went
around and like I'll talk to two or
three friends and they're like nah you
know not for me not for me and then like
I'll see the ad somewhere and I'll be
like oh they found a home yep right and
it does make you think a little bit as
to like what's going on yeah and I think
even as far as the gambling stuff goes
you know those companies have to do
their thing right like they they got to
make ads and same with creators like
they need to do that too and so I want
to like follow up with my previous
statement by saying like I've also done
some and probably will continue to do
some of those ads I think like just with
those like the messaging has to be right
you know so I don't want someone to
watch this podcast and see me post an ad
for a company and be like you you liar
yeah
but but I think that there is this like
um people talk all the time about
product Market fit right and uh uh you
know very well understood now in the
startup world but like one of the things
that we have found uh across you know I
mean I talked to a lot of people who
have audiences who who are kind of in
this world and over and over and over
again people are like look
if I find the right brand that aligns
with me my values my ethics whatever uh
and
with my audience and what they're
looking for or whatever fill a need that
they're trying to to find a solution to
it's a home run oh yeah and sometimes
people forget like there's distractions
right there's money there's uh views
there's like all these different they
sometimes they're just being associated
with a certain brand right some people
are like oh that's gonna be better for
me or whatever
um but if you can align those three
things like it ends up being a win-win
uh for the person who's creating the
content for the brand and then ultimate
for the audience as well definitely I
mean I think
I think I kind of like to see those uh
the brand relationships the same way you
would see like you know romantic
relationships right like explain uh so
there are
there are companies that you can work
with very briefly uh you know there's
some instant gratification and one night
stand correct
um
and so I think a lot of people are you
know I don't think it's the worst thing
in the world I just think a lot of
people are like tempted with taking
those deals
um and then there are companies that
like I've found for example where I'm
like I will get on my knee and ask you
to marry me like let's just sign the
biggest contract we can if you want to
sign for 10 years let's do it you know
um and so yeah I just I think that like
I think those two are strangely similar
um but yeah I think it is totally a home
run like if you can find a brand that
works perfectly I think another big
thing too
um is like how the people are at the
brand like the people who you interact
with are they cool are they paying to
work with
um so yeah I mean if you can find a
brand with cool people that do something
that your audience is interested in that
you're interested in and that have the
budget like yes I'm laughing because
I've had all the experiences some of
them you're like amazing like literally
you got I'll go to bat for you all day
long like whatever I can do to help you
others you're like when is the contract
over right and what I've found actually
is the people in the second situation
they're almost never like they don't
want to be doing it either right like
there's you know you mentioned earlier
compliance stuff there's uh sometimes uh
uh executive team that's like
overbearing or trying to call the shots
or what like there's a bunch of
different reasons why stuff yeah it's
dumb stuff and everyone knows it's dumb
but like it's just the situation they
find themselves in
um and so what I always remind them is
if you're easy to work with and we
understand your goals
there's a whole bunch of stuff that we
can do because we can see opportunistic
stuff and like we used to do these live
stream
um kind of like one-off things right so
like especially during 2020 I would just
be at home and just like you know what I
got some stuff to say and I just hit you
know live stream on YouTube or whatever
and at the end there'll be q a people
ask me questions and so like if I was
working with an Advertiser that like I
really believed in and I understood what
they were trying to accomplish and
everything somebody asked me a question
about one of our advertisers is so and
so like here's why I like them but
whatever like that's not part of a
contract that's not anything
it's just you want like you believe it's
a solution for the audience right
today's episode is brought to you by
Exodus you can use exodus to buy crypto
for zero fees for a limited time they
just launched a brand new wallet that
allows you to use one wallet across all
the different networks ethereum Solana
polygon or whatever else you want to use
if you go to exodus.com pump you can go
ahead and use that wallet or you can buy
Bitcoin ethereum or any other crypto
asset you can use your bank account your
credit card Apple pay or Google pay
Exodus is here for you head on over to
exodus.com pomp today to get started
exodus.com pump they support us you go
support them yeah 100 and I mean I do
that all the time too where like if a
brand is really really fair
um you know they're you guys like
mutually agree on you know how many
posts you have to make how much money
they're giving you oftentimes like I'll
go out and wear you know
some Brands hat on a podcast or like you
know I'll mention them in a live stream
or like you know show a little extra
love on like their social media accounts
or something like that
um and so yeah I think it's just about
like trying to have like the most
reasonable and like amicable
relationship talk to people about
Grandma you you your your grandmother is
now Tick Tock famous uh from what I
understand you showed me some of the
videos and they're hilarious
yeah um so it's around a year ago now
that we started okay
um my goal was to kind of figure out
whether or not I had gotten lucky right
I kind of hit like this wall where I was
like
maybe a little bored of what I was doing
and I was like
let's do a test so I wanted everything
to be working against me that was my
goal I didn't want to be able to like
plug the page anywhere else I didn't
want to be in the videos
um and so I took my grandma for a few
reasons uh I guess a because it's
difficult because she's
no offense no not old
um and she said hey she looks like she's
21 but she you know she's a little up
there you would never guess it uh and
people on Tick Tock are super young
right so like how do you get young
people to be interested in an old person
that's probably a unique Challenge on
Tick Tock
um and so we started making these videos
and I kind of like sat down one day and
just obviously like knowing and being
close to her my whole life kind of wrote
down like the things that uh I was most
interested in and that I saw people who
she knew were most interested in when it
comes to like her personality
um and so like it's just great stories
right like she's uh
she's an immigrant she came here from
Italy like at 18 by herself uh obviously
couldn't speak English like she's got a
really interesting story so stories and
her cooking so I was like What if I just
combine these a little bit and so uh
she'll she does these cooking videos uh
and she'll just add in like little
tidbits of like you know I remember back
in Italy we used to eat this dish
because you know like I think she was
talking about beans and like they
couldn't afford meat so they had beans
and whatever like these heartwarming
stories
um that I think like a very specific
niche of people can appreciate to like
an extreme level because it's so rare on
the internet
um but it's also like something that
people just generally would see and you
know even if you're you don't really
care about like Italian culture or like
most people would look at that and be
like oh she's cute so yeah we started
that uh huh is she making cash
so a little
uh but she probably could be doing much
better I just it's a time thing yeah you
know I think at this point it's more of
a it's more like a passion thing
um because she also like loves it you
know it's like something for her to do
she probably never thought that she'd be
really doing anything like I guess this
isn't like real like work for her but uh
you know it's like it's something she's
got to show up and she's gotta like she
obviously like has to be uh she has to
perform on camera does she get like does
she put like specific clothes on and
like oh yeah and she's like oh this is
my look here today like do I look good
uh yeah because she's like she's super
old school so she like she wants to make
sure that like do I look good is my hair
right is my shirt good like she's uh
she's really funny I also got really
lucky with her too because like her she
has a great personality so like I don't
think it would have worked with anyone
um but yeah she's a great personality
like she laughs a lot it's like it's a
personal thing too because like you know
it gets us to spend more time together
uh so like it's like a bond thing and
then also I realized like
obviously it'd be cool to like make her
a bunch of money but I think
more than anything I wanna
I wanna like take responsibility for
like making her live the best years of
her life at a point in her life where
most people don't right like usually uh
people have their best years when
they're super young so it's like who's
to say that she she can't like just have
a great few years yeah so like uh I
guess like some of the ways that I've
done that is like
um we spoke about carrot before they do
this whole thing where they now like get
Billboards in Times Square for like a
bunch of uh creators and so I surprised
her with a billboard in Times Square
with like a picture of the two of us
which was like just the most ridiculous
thing what was the reaction oh my gosh
she was crying I swear to you for hours
like these guys were here were there and
like she was because it was like it was
super emotional for her because like she
was saying that like she she immediately
thought back to like when she got here
and obviously things were much different
back then uh so she took a boat here and
it was like whatever nine days she was
by herself 18 years old
when she got here it wasn't like uh you
know let me call my dad because her dad
was already here like let me call my Dad
and tell him to come pick me up right
like they didn't have cell phones
obviously like they didn't a lot of like
small like logistical things that we
wouldn't think about
um so she was like you know I couldn't I
remember like you know getting to the
port finding my dad we walked to Times
Square and like that was like the first
thing that you did when she got here
and so I remember her saying that like
uh because of like some of the like
adversity that she had faced like
through her life she always felt like
she was
I guess like in a way like less than
like a lot of people who had more
opportunity uh because like she didn't
get to go to college like she didn't get
to live like the classic like nine to
five life uh and so I think like that
made her like especially emotional
because it was like oh well in in a
world where like my entire life I didn't
think that I could ever impact a lot of
people or do things that you know most
people can't do uh I'm doing that right
and so it's like I think that kind of
made her emotional to like remember
going to Times Square all the way back
when she came here and now to going to
Times Square and like you know massive
billboard yeah I mean with a million
followers on Tick Tock do you think that
you can get her to make more money in a
single year now than she made in her
entire life oh yeah yeah it's kind of
crazy definitely definitely
um
yeah it's it's nuts
um and like I said I haven't done that
but I should why not yeah like I said
it's mostly like a time thing
um and also it's
maybe it isn't mostly a time thing I
think it's also partially about like
doing it right as well like right now
we're working on merch
um as we're like for me I don't think my
merch would crush it yeah but with her
and this is like an interesting thing
like that I learned through this about
like the differences between people's
audiences is like she has a much more
attached audience like I swear to you
every time she leaves the house
someone is like I need to take a picture
with you no no Gracie I love she's
getting stopped in the streets all the
time every single like literally every
every time she leaves the house
um and she loves you like it it's gotten
to the point yeah she loves it uh it's
gotten to the point where like she
doesn't even mention it to me anymore
like in the beginning she was like oh my
God this is crazy someone you know
someone recognized me can you believe it
and now she's just like she's like a
celebrity of course they did it's
regular to her yeah oh my god
um and so yeah her audience is like
super attached and a lot of them are
like you know I lost my grandma like
however many years or months ago and so
like uh like Nona Gracie just really
resonates with me and it like reminds me
of my grandma or whatever it may be so
yeah super cool and so like yeah we're
working on merch
um
also looking at like some sort of Avenue
to like kind of monetize her recipes
maybe like a cookbook or a recipe
subscription or something along those
lines but it's a no-brainer yeah yeah I
think so too
um
yeah so thanks I'm inspired now I'm
gonna I'm gonna make it listen I'm gonna
make her a million dollars what
um uh what are the steps so like
somebody watches this like all right
cool I got it tick tock's big I should
be on Tick Tock uh I want to build an
account what would you say are like the
three to five steps that somebody should
do immediately to grow on tick tock
um yeah okay so I guess
step number one is like figure out your
Lane right like what are you interested
in and it could be anything I think you
see a lot of people who will decide
Things based off of like we'll decide
what they're making videos about based
off what they think what will what will
do well
um
I really think anything could do well
right I think it just depends on how you
present it
um but there there is a market for
everything I mean
you know obviously different different
uh like niches are are like different
sizes but like for example if you
absolutely own the basket weaving Niche
like you could probably monetize that
really heavily even if like the maximum
capability for like your follower
account is like 50 000. that could be
like a gross underestimation so basket
weaving Community don't come at me but
um all right so first is I think it's
finding your lane making sure it's like
true to you
um and then from there I think uh
I think consuming a lot of content at
least in the beginning around the type
of content that you content that you
want to make is super important just to
like see you know what other people are
doing and how other people are doing
what you want to do well
um so I think that's like the second
step
and then I think especially with Tick
Tock it's just like go right like just
do it
um which is like I guess like very
cliche to say but like the it's almost
like the more planning you do like the
more like
like theories you come up with like
maybe this will do better as we're like
with a tick tock video you could make
one in 10 15 30 minutes max if like
you're really trying to make a good
video
um so it's like how about you just test
it you know
um and so I think that's kind of what I
did was like
exactly those steps and like just kind
of tested things until they worked
um and I sort of like leaned in on the
the things the topics that worked and
tried to like you know uh remake them in
a way and like kind of stuck with a
format and yeah just like kept going and
then at some point like obviously when
you get to a certain amount of followers
um Brands start to reach out or you can
like reach out to Brands and like
they'll be interested in working with
you and then from there I think it's
important to just like continue running
it as a business like a lot of people I
think don't do that and I think that
that's probably like one of the bigger
like mistakes that I see so I want to
ask you a bunch of just rapid fire
questions uh the first is if you had to
pick one Tick Tock account that you
think absolutely crushes it but people
don't really know about it what would
you say
oh
the BlackRock Tick Tock
I'm kidding I'm kidding um
well actually no okay I I do believe
that but I won't pick that because it's
too corny
um hmm
okay so this is
can I modify the question too it should
be bigger okay
um there's a guy's name is JT Barnett
um he makes like crater economy content
and he's a bunch of followers like he's
crushing it
um but I think he should be doing better
interesting what's one Trend in this
whole Creator economy thing that uh you
disagree with or you think doesn't have
legs to stay
um have you seen that there's a there's
a new trend where people like
I suppose like Freestyle a song
like telling a random story have you
seen this no there's like an
instrumental that everybody uses I'm I
forget the name of the actual song but
everyone basically throws on this
instrumental and they'll tell a story
but pretend like they're like singing
but they're like it's it's always
terrible like they're half singing and
they're nothing like Rhymes or goes
together it's just it's really weird to
me I don't know what you just described
not only doesn't sound like it's Gonna
Last I'm surprised it ever became a
thing yeah like yeah it is huge like
some of these videos have like millions
of likes and I'm like I cannot bear to
like stand stand more than 10 seconds of
this that's crazy
um who do you think is the most likely
person from The Creator economy to go on
to build massive businesses uh similar
to a Mr Beast but hasn't yet started
like who do you think has the biggest
opportunity
uh who hasn't yet started at all I mean
I think like the note boys are doing a
good job with doing what Mr Beast
is doing but obviously at a smaller
scale uh but they've already started
um
I would just say anyone with like anyone
with like an extremely because if you
have a if you have a really captivated
audience I think people this is probably
a longer answer than you wanted uh but
like I think you realize at some point
that instead of promoting things that
are in line with my brand that are owned
by other people why wouldn't I just go
and own those things right so uh I think
anyone for example like my grandma has
big potential for that right like she
could
theoretically like she could start like
a whole merch brand surrounding like the
Italian culture and it could explode
right like tomato sauce the whole thing
yeah yeah she could yeah she could she
could go into like you know consumer
goods and start selling things in in
grocery stores and like
that would be that would be wild I think
she's got potential if you had to pick
YouTube Instagram Tick Tock you get to
upload one video to go viral which one
has the highest probability of going
Tick Tock if you had to pick one of
those three platforms to build an entire
business around which one would you pick
YouTube if you had to pick one for the
highest degree of Creator satisfaction
which would you pick
I think it's a toss-up between Tick Tock
and YouTube but I think I'll go with
Tick Tock okay you [ __ ] all over
Instagram and all three of those answers
and didn't pick them for anything what
why do you think Instagram maybe doesn't
keep up with the other two platforms
I I don't know yeah I guess I'm not the
biggest fan of Instagram it's just like
I think Tick Tock and YouTube are just
really running it right now because all
that Instagram really has going for them
is like they don't even push like photos
and stuff anymore you know like which is
like their whole thing yeah so it's like
I feel like Instagram's kind of just
trying to be Tick Tock right now yeah
um but it so yes but doesn't that make
it easier for the people creating
content where like it used to be like
long form YouTube video photos on
Instagram Tick Tock video whatever now
it's just like 60 seconds or less
vertical video put in all three
platforms and like you're definitely I
just think I think long term it's like
at what point do the consumers get bored
like if Instagram just keeps doing what
they're doing
and I could be wrong this is like pure
speculation but like if they keep doing
what they're doing at what point do
users realize like I could just be on
tick tock you know like do I do I need
all of these accounts and things going
on
um I don't know
I think that at some point that could
happen when you meet somebody at a bar
and they ask you what you do what do you
say
this is a funny this is a funny question
uh I'll usually just be like
um in social media
I think especially because like as the
years have gone by it's gotten more and
more complicated right like am I the
social media consultant guy do I make
videos do I build brands for other
people and so like if they if they're
really interested and they'll like
continue the conversation I'll like
explain more but it also depends on like
who it is you know like is it's if it's
like a random person you know like
someone
like a family friends friend or
something who's like 60 years old and
they're like what do you do I'll be like
I'm in marketing yeah just leave it at
that you know
it's definitely not even happy except
for your grandma Yeah she knows exactly
what's going on she knows she knows do
you think that she tells her friends oh
she does yeah yeah she loves it no I
don't think they're jealous some have
offered to like feature in her videos
because she's got like a whole Squad of
like old Italian women yeah well and
they want oh they want cameos yeah yeah
and so they're just like maybe one day
I'll hop in your video you know so and
she hasn't taken them up on it yet no I
think we're totally open to it like we
probably will it would be a good idea
people are gonna talk maybe I can start
accounts for all of them and just build
this like Army of uh of nonas
I I'm imagining her there uh my wife's
grandmother uh or I guess
great-grandmother uh she
um uh was on the news in Bulgaria
because uh my wife was uh interviewed in
Bulgarian media and she mentioned her
great-grandmother
who of course they pulled a photo and so
she's like calling all of her friends
and uh she's like did you see the news I
was on the news like basically talking
[ __ ] and being like you've never been on
the news oh my God I was on the news
that is the news cares about me they
don't care about you basically and she's
like you know I don't know 92 93 years
old yeah she thinks she's 100 but she's
92.
and uh I remember just thinking like man
that never leaves you it's like that is
amazing yeah I don't think I don't think
Nona's gotten to the point of confidence
yet where she's like necessarily flexing
about it I think it's more so just like
sharing things where she's like I am
shocked that this is happening you know
like so call her friends and be like I
was on a billboard in Times Square does
that make any sense to you kind of thing
you know like uh like did you see the
picture and it's funny because like she
doesn't have a phone she has no idea how
to operate oh she didn't even have a
phone no no no
uh so like everything basically is
through me right like I'll read her
comments and whatever and so it's funny
because like so like uh she'll be like
can you print this picture of us so I
can show my friends and I'll be like oh
yeah it's right like you can't text your
friends the picture because none of you
have phones you know so her friends
don't have phones either so they're like
yeah they really are you know fax
machine and print yeah yeah and then she
like show up and be like here's pictures
of all the scenes of my Tick Tock that
went viral imagine she's got like one of
those like books that you flipped yeah
and then she shows them like what the
tick tock is no no no no no she'll just
like she'll ask me it's mainly just for
like big things like that yeah you know
I think really it was just the Times
Square billboard but now it's like an
interesting story so I tell it more
dramatically
um but yeah yeah so either she'll like
ask me to show them in person or you
know something like that or like one of
their like grandkids will show them
that's uh I think that's what grandkids
are for it's like hey look what's going
on on these internet things yeah and
then they're like get off the internet
don't put your credit card on there yeah
it's also weird because I think like uh
some people I think even like younger
people but you know the numbers behind
the screen it just seems like a game but
I think in person as she started to get
recognized more she un starts to
understand the numbers more now you know
yeah I think it's true for everyone
though right of just like the numbers
don't seem real and at some point they
do start to see more whether it's a
conversion on something that you post or
whatever but like there is this like
this is a game then like oh these were
people that are watching uh which is
kind of a weird thing when it happens
definitely
um where can we send people to follow
you on the internet
mattress yeah across everything yeah uh
well on Instagram it's like real
macrasia but I'm sure if you just put
mattress yeah it'll come up are you big
on Twitter
no no unfortunately do you have a
Twitter I should be big on Twitter yeah
do you have Twitter I do have a Twitter
I just don't really use it why don't you
just put the videos from tick tock on
Twitter
does that get engagement
uh little Alpha for you because I know
you use Twitter more than everything
else yeah uh they are now testing like a
carousel in the middle of the feed it's
like you start scrolling and all of a
sudden it's like trending videos I'm
like
I'm confused so like they're doing
something with video I don't know if I'm
in like some sort of like test cohort I
don't know if they've actually rolled
this out to everyone or whatever but I
see the carousel there and it's already
I'm like should I be putting more video
on Twitter like are they about to go
full you know Tick Tock and like just
like yeah boost all the videos I don't
know we'll see yeah I think um
I definitely need to start focusing on
Twitter more now I think Twitter is like
a space where like a lot of like I guess
like industry people connect right yeah
like is what LinkedIn should have been
right exactly and so I think especially
now with like Fusion stuff uh
I'm definitely trying to connect with
more people like that so there's nothing
more powerful than Twitter uh than a
Twitter DM to somebody who's been
following you for years
yeah like definitely I think right like
email likely going to be missed ignored
you know whatever it's hard to like
remember who's who whatever uh if you
get a ton of emails uh Instagram and
Tick Tock are still like okay maybe but
like that's like for most people it's
like personal stuff they're not doing a
lot of work stuff there they're accounts
are locked on Instagram or whatever but
Twitter's like this weird thing where
it's like personal and professional yeah
uh and if you follow people consume lots
of their content then they DM you you
respond yeah
yeah I think um and also Twitter is
interesting because I didn't know this
but my buddy Nate mentioned to me that
like Twitter has like insane organic
reach
yeah and I never knew that like I guess
he was saying it's basically like Tick
Tock with words
uh two degree yeah I mean there's
there's months in a single month
uh I'm trying to think probably the
biggest month ever uh nurses publicly
some people are gonna freak out
exclusive uh I think we did like 300 or
350 million impressions oh my goodness
in a single month like those are Tick
Tock numbers maybe like 180 000
followers like net new followers whoa
like it's that's crazy and now that's
like the absolute craziest it's ever
gotten and like I was tweeting a lot
like you know all these things uh that
were like kind of Tailwinds for it
um but yeah I mean it's like pretty big
if you're like
if you're playing your A-game in an
industry that's hot and Twitter's like
not screwing around a bunch of bots and
stuff which they are right now yeah uh
like yeah I mean it's a platform that
can go is the deal with Elon gonna go
through
I'm 50 50. and the 50
uh yes is like he wants to do it now
well maybe he doesn't want to do it he's
going to do it now uh the 50 no is uh I
think there's like a little bit of an
outlier chance that like the government
blocks it interesting like they're they
claim that they're going to review it or
there's like rumors that they're gonna
do a National Security review for what I
guess what's their fear well if you're
Elon Musk and you have SpaceX and Tesla
you're heavily dependent on government
contracts and also like go to the
extreme uh Tesla is now producing cars
in China he's very dependent on selling
cars in China if China shows up and it's
like hey by the way if you want to
continue to produce your cars here like
this Twitter thing let me let's have a
conversation about what we're going to
do there
uh-huh like again it's a stretch but
it's not a stretch right like you can
sort of just understand both sides of it
uh and so like man what if the story was
like all the nonsense all the debate all
the stuff whatever and then like the
government blocks it and he doesn't end
up having to spend 44 billion dollars
for a company that's not worth 44
billion dollars because the government
blocked it
yeah that would be pretty nuts as he
says all the time like the most
entertaining outcome is the most likely
mm-hmm
like Joe Biden saved Elon Musk 44
billion is not the headline that anyone
is expecting but like I don't know
there's a 50 50 shot of that happening
yeah yeah
that's crazy
huh like
all right well in there I appreciate you
coming again uh thanks so much and uh
we'll continue to do this and definitely
have to do it again in the future as
grandma gets more famous I appreciate it
yeah we'll get around here one day